- Tyler James Williams was
here, another cast member,
and he said Quinta used
things from his personal life.
All of a sudden, they
would appear in an episode.
And I love it 'cause
like, I'm a writer too.
Be careful who you date.
Like I'm just saying. So does -
- Ah.
- What?
- Does she?
No, you can't talk yet.
Wait, does she do that to y'all too?
- Absolutely. She will.
(Kelly and Lisa laugh)
I made one mistake.
- Hold on.
- What, what?
(Lisa and audience laugh)
- Look, can I say something?
- Yes. Sure.
- Okay. What I would like to
say is, is Tyler was a little,
he was half right, half wrong.
Tyler says Tyler happens to be similar
to Gregory in some ways.
That's the truth.
- [Lisa, Sheryl, and Kelly] Yes.
He just happens to be similar to him.
Tyler is very, he has his paths,
he has the way he sees things,
and he has the way he likes things done.
Now the Sheryl thing, I
just wanna say this is one
where she's gonna say is 100% true.
So I just wanna set that up,
that Tyler was half wrong.
Sheryl's completely right. So go ahead.
(audience laughs)
- What? What did she do to you?
- Okay, so I just wanna say,
when you hear the name Darren Star,
tell me you don't think of a
six-foot basketball player.
Now you know Darren Star
sounds like a Black man.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
Thank you.
I got it wrong. Now you know.
Orlando Bloom.
- Yes.
- Tell me you don't think about
a nice bruising football
player, Black man.
Okay, so I got it wrong.
It was the wrong Orlando.
- [Quinta] Right.
And it was funny.
- And it was funny.
- She ends up writing
a whole episode,
- [Kelly] It's so funny.
- Cold open.
(audience cheers)
- It's so funny.
- My favorite was -
- It was hilarious.
- [Lisa] It was hilarious.
- It was that look at that
little Carrie Underwood.
- Little Carrie Underwood.
That was so good.
- It was really funny to us in the moment
because it was me in my room.
We didn't understand the
logic of how Sheryl saw it.
We were like, so wait, is it Black actors
who she thinks are white?
Or is it just a name mix up?
And I was like, what if it's everything
and we can get that to
Barbara and it'll be good.